salut moi c'est saïd ici on est à la
joliverie je suis en maintenance
véhicules électriques et hybrides
on est actuellement à l'atelier nous les
mécaniciens on est plus les mêmes
mécanismes qu'avant la maintenance
véhicules électriques
c'est franchement tout nouveau je
pensais pas que je dois mettre des gants
des slogans protection c'est un nouveau
métier
cette formation est tout à fait
nécessaire dans le cadre de ces
nouvelles motorisations il y à de
nouvelles compétences à saisir du point
de vue maintenance les domaines de
tension qui habituellement est tourné
autour d'une batterie 12 volts font
qu'aujourd'hui la chaîne de traction du
véhicule et sont environ 300 volts ça
impose des procédures dans chaque
intervention d'affaires sera un véhicule
électrique et hybride
on est obligé de faire un balisage pour
éviter n'importe quel individu qui n'est
pas habilité à rentrer dans la zone de
maintenance sur la voiture électrique
c'est d'abord b est essentiellement la
maintenance de base comme tout véhicule
à ces véhicules à présent des
pneumatiques présente des freins mais on
va dire en véhicules électriques il suce
très peu un véhicule électrique
nécessite tellement peu de maintenance
par rapport à un véhicule thermique que
s'il est bien conçue dès le départ en
fait c'est un véhicule qui vous donnera
toute satisfaction pendant très
longtemps
par contre s'il ya un souci un problème
une difficulté bien entendu là il faudra
passer par des ateliers dont les
personnels auront été formés à
travailler notamment en sécurité il faut
savoir que dans cette formation ils
voient pas que le côté maintenance
véhicules électriques et hybrides mais
aussi le côté
carrosserie trains roulants motorisation
diagnostic de ce que pourrait être un
bon technicien dans ce domaine là la
maintenance véhicules électriques
hybrides faut savoir que cela englobe
énormément de domaines il est
indispensable de former ces jeunes à ces
nouvelles technologies les véhicules
électriques sont essentiellement lancé
depuis cinq six ans donc en âge moyen
véhicule ce sont des véhicules qu'on
voit de plus en plus se retrouver dans
dans les ateliers de maintenance c'est
une formation qui se veut un petit peu
finalistes à savoir on fait ça plus tôt
idéalement derrière un bts maintenance
des véhicules
on ne s'interdit pas non plus des gens
qui arrivent de maintenance des
bâtiments les bts autour des métiers
l'électricité de même que la conception
des produits industriels etc
on est formés à ce monde-là ce monde de
demain où les voitures électriques
seront banane entre guillemets